all right so so here's the thing you
wake up you open your phone what's the
first thing you check what's the first
app you open it's whatever the
notifications are really yeah look at
the notifications i kind of like look at
is there any of these which are like
super important any of these are they
ever ever any super important sometimes
sometimes you wake up and like shit's
gone wrong or something and you're like
my line messages really are the first
ones where i'm like oh yes this requires
immediate attention everything else like
whatever if it's email then it's not
going to be important no because if if
some if someone i don't know if you see
if i see a video if i wake up and i see
an email from youtube i'm like okay no
that [ __ ] spot
that's when my heart sinks no no
youtuber ever wants to see an email from
youtube it's literally like you never
want to hear from your boss
if you get a youtube it sucks right
because sometimes youtube will email you
email you'll be like here's the
community roundup of stuff it's like
[ __ ] off youtube you scared me because
normally it means a copyright claim or
something so youtubers are scared to
death of seeing anything related to
youtube in there
it's like a copyright claim or worse
like your channel has been terminated or
your your video has been adressed yeah
your video has been age-related nothing
nothing good ever comes out of a youtube
email like i could like get a youtube
email being like we've decided to send
you one million dollars for being such a
good youtuber and i'd i'd like i'd still
get a [ __ ] heart attack or something
true true
uh
hmm
probably
i think i'd go through my notifications
first obviously yes i'll check it you
know line uh i mean you know do you have
multiple messaging apps like that people
can contact you on do you have a
personal like number one priority app
that one that like this is the one where
if you message me on here i will
actually see it in reply uh yeah to me
it's like line and facebook messenger
yeah facebook messenger is like that's a
[ __ ] lie you don't respond to your
life
well that's uh like god doesn't respond
to me god does not respond to messages
actually impossible i i respond to
messages when i check my messages and i
i do not check my messages when i get
notifications that's that's what that's
just what i have to do you were like my
friend from i read a friend from school
right and he was always kind of he's
always kind of a little odd but he's a
good friend we just play xbox a lot
but he was just always so stoic
and and very strange with like
communication
like we would we'd always play xbox
right but then summer holidays would
come around he'd be like alright guys
guys i'm just not going to talk to you
all summer and we're like all right but
he wouldn't it would disappear all
summer
and i was like okay strange and whenever
you messaged him you'd see him at school
you're like yo why don't you apply my
messages i didn't want to and i was like
we would be like what
what an [ __ ] yeah yeah
and then um at prom right
yeah we're at prom and uh we're like
we're just having a good time and then
we're like yeah dude we should grab some
drinks and then i promise like i'm never
going to see any of you guys ever again
and we are like we're like wow we were
like what wow
and then but to this day we know
two three years later he messaged us on
facebook
and we played during the it might have
been when was fortnight popular
what did four when was the engine like
the biggest thing two or three years ago
yeah whenever that happened yeah i
played like a few games of fortnite one
day and then haven't heard from him
again
so
that was that's interesting last online
nine years ago yeah actually i i know
what he's up to because my friend is
my friend's dad is best friends with his
dad so yeah
so i i i he
yeah he's alive he's doing well he's
doing well he doesn't want to see you
you know i get it some people want to
move on after school i get it but like i
don't know to me it was like damn this
man was sure
it's not like he was getting like
bullied or anything
we were his friends we were literally
his friends well clearly not we hung out
with him more than anyone and the
skyrise decided that he was just done
he's like friendship over you know this
man like just did the irl friendship
remove in front of us and like and like
we thought he was like joking friendship
with connor ended fortnight is my friend
now yeah we met up with i met up with
some of my friends back in the uk who
were it was the two friends so we had a
friend group of four of us and it was
yeah the three of us and not him uh we
met up and we were just like yeah that
was weird huh how he just he really was
a man of his word to the end ah he
really just uh just disappeared he
literally just went through his facebook
friend list and we entire realm and
we're just like guys i'm gonna i'm gonna
start clearing off my friend list
if i unfriend you don't worry about it
it's just weird right because he he
didn't delete any of us on facebook and
yeah i think if i messaged him he'd
reply but he just was like i'm never
gonna ever make an effort to talk to you
ever again
it's true the man knows what he wants
right in some ways i respect the
conviction i i wish i had i wish i had
that amount of conviction at age 18 to
decide to make a life choice like that
to just cut people out
yeah i mean i mean how many of the
people you still
like met 18 or friends with in high
school do you still keep in contact with
high school
uh like actually a fair amount
occasionally just because it was very
small yeah i still have like a facebook
group of like all my friends it was a
really small town so it's a lot easier
to
you know you you knew everyone yeah and
you know your parents know everyone so
it's really hard not to like have some
form of like oh this so-and-so is up to
this and stuff yeah that's weird for me
because i remember whenever i go like
visit sydney's hometown in sydney's
family should we we'd just be like go
shopping to a supermarket or like going
in town and she'd be like oh yeah she uh
taught me history in high school yeah
and i'm just like i can't imagine ever
like running into my teacher in in
normal life because if that happens like
in my city it's like defcon 5. you know
like something bad's gone wrong oh cc my
my teachers emailed me they're like
really yeah because they told me to i
did i say i went and gave a presentation
at school yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah did right yeah they because my
my older
teacher guy reached out to me and he was
like hey
he's like no actually no the students
reached out okay but then he like he
liked me so he was like hey conor yeah
come on over come on in and so i can i
can just like
walk in so here's the thing right i'm
speaking to an american and this is so
okay this is this is gonna sound like
another connors american story yeah we
were sitting there and i and uh so they
were from florida
and uh we were talking about this and
they were like wait so there's like no
security at your school i was like no
there's no security at my school
they're like what if like something bad
happens i'm like
bad things don't happen at school yeah
this is school
what do you mean like the teachers can
handle it yeah what do you mean it's
kids it's like it's fine like what if
someone comes in with a gun no one has
guns but nobody knows no 12 year olds
have guns
there's like there's no metal detectors
no no
that's crazy
you think we can afford metal detectors
yeah we can barely afford chairs
we're like we've been using the same
chairs for like the past 80 years in my
school we don't have chairs
like if you're in a school and you had
to open up the textbook and you didn't
have to share your [ __ ] textbooks
yeah you knew you're in a good [ __ ]
school yeah yeah so like i could like
you know i could if if i was going in
you know one of the if i just said one
of the teachers is like gonna just ask
me to come in you know even if they
don't know anything i just i can just
walk in and be like hey the
school told me i was i was coming and
they're like oh okay cool because they
like know who i am yeah so because i was
the next student yeah and even if it's
like a good school it's like the most
you have to do is maybe like you know go
to the reception and say like hey i'm
here for dude and then you can just go
in right you don't have to go through
this whole like prison scene yeah yeah i
was like
what do you mean you don't have to go
through the tsa every time you go to
school yeah and then when i was done i
just went around to speak to the
teachers that i liked and i was like hi
how are you doing are you doing well
nice yeah nice cool cool how's life yep
still teaching cool god
nice imagine going to school that's
actually safe yeah
oh my god worst thing that happened was
[ __ ] me climbing a tree and then
nearly just jumping out of it and
that's the worst thing
i thought he was like you getting into
fights or something yeah yeah yeah yeah
did you have to go to detention for that
like what punishment system did you have
in your school
nothing physical i assume in this day
and age
no yeah no maybe
i think some of the teachers would have
loved to though yeah some are some of
the older ones i could tell
they were more than happy to try it like
undoing the belt
now now oh
um yeah did you guys have detention in
your school yeah of course we we had a
thing um a couple was called him welsh
what is it you sit in a room
facing a wall
it's like a tiny tiny room yeah you just
face a wall yeah and we have the same
thing where our teachers would just tell
students to just look at the [ __ ]
corner
like go stand on the wall right
and that's how it was until i entered
high school right because to me the the
word detention that was an american
thing right that was an american
punishment yeah us our school was in
britain we just stood up we just looked
at a wall
we looked at that we called it blair
witching
you know whenever i got into f i think i
only went there once and that was from
one of the fights yeah but most of the
time i went like full lawyer mode when i
was a kid i was like hell no your honor
you hit me first there is no way i'm
doing self-defense
and then i think one time they were like
you need to go to the headshot like i'm
not going to detention they're like what
do you mean why i'm like because you hit
me [ __ ] i'm not going in detention
and then they were like hmm
i think i i would have gone in detention
if they actually made me do it yeah you
know but i was like trying to fight back
and what the [ __ ] did they didn't make
me go see like i i didn't have the balls
to like retaliate i think what after i'd
gotten a fight like adrenaline was like
high yeah i think i was willing to fight
back but most of the time i'd be like
okay i think the reason why i could
never retaliate to my teachers is
because like in my head i was like
if i did that to my dad for instance
he'd beat my ass so like oh no he wants
to say that the teacher's not going to
beat my ass as well all right that's why
i was conditioned
like i know that if my teachers called
out my parents which i did multiple
times
they would kill me they would actually
kill me they would like take away my
xbox for like two weeks and i'd rather
frankly sure
they honestly could like could leave me
out to dry with no food yeah easy right
i'll do that take my xbox away for two
weeks all right real [ __ ] right now okay
now now i'm gonna do anything possible
to your voice they never told me that
there was a fate worse than death
i legitimately they could take away they
could like starve me for three days i'd
be like as long as i have my halo 3 copy
and halo reach i'll be fine like
legitimately i'm pretty sure i would
have preferred that yeah
so i avoided it but i know the one thing
the one thing that my parents would like
have my back on is if someone started a
fight with me and i fought back so i was
always very confident right right i was
like yeah were you do tell my parents
yeah they'll they'll tell me good on you
they'll be like my son's good
did he win
wipe you out
pour some water on me though
[Laughter]
it's genuinely the only things where i
felt like i could get away with doing it
because my parents legitimately would
have my back yeah but that's why i
didn't mind fighting max i know that i'd
you know if i
if i genuinely felt like i was in a
position to fight back i would
it worked but you know i wouldn't
recommend it for everyone yeah
if you're if you fight back and and you
lose it's
which just high risk just high risk yeah
we spoke about that about you yeah all
right i need a piss carter the
psychopath
i gotta make piss